Đóng thùng đần Rator Zeloi một quan trực kỳ răng emy mặt một trực két
khoảng 2 người bao gồm có lửa an link đã tiền mạng cho các cuộc biểu tình giao dài hình hai tình qua
Nên dấu lên đầu tiên chính quyền y ra ngờ nhận lúc thùng bòng rất lượng sầu trẻ dịch trấn áp
Vì quan trực cáu buộc tổn tại thành phần cùng bố lưỡng sầu cây chết của càng ở biểu tình
và những cái an link sông còn cũng có kế phục đi chết kết
các hạn truyền thông tin bao gồm biệt giản đoạn internet đang cảm trở kiểm trứng đốc lập số liệu thông bong và vật giữ trong khi nhiều khổ chức của thế cho rằng
tổng xuống người chết và bị bắt có thể cao phần nhiều sổng gọi số chính thức mạnh hiéran đưa ra
nhiều video lên chuyển trên mặt số quay cũng cho thấy hàng rài các tủ đựa từ thế đang trở được người thần xa nhận
Chụi đỏ lần xuống biểu tình từ iran đủ phát từng em tạo của mấy hai dò của phản phình thế
Đồng nối tệ mất giả mạnh và lạm phát tăng tự bố mấy phần chăm, sau đó lần dọng thành có cuộc tổn hạnh và bộ y rửa rửa rửa rửa sạo xí cầm quyền
Các tham càng gió tăng khi ngày mi hai một tổn của mình đúng là trong tiên bố áp thế nhất cầu, khảm lạm thần chăm
Lối với bất kỳ cũng ra nào còn dấu thường với iran, Washington được cho là đã lên phần án tần công quân sự
để đáp trả trên dịch trình áp được tình của thế iran, iran cho biết tận vý trị có kênh liên lạc với Washington